y en directo a vamos a esta ciudad de
México allí saludamos a nuestro
corresponsal Mario carbonel para conocer
detalles sobre cómo respondió el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador a
las protestas que se dieron este domingo
en todo el país y que rechazan su
polémica reforma electoral que fue
aprobada por el senado la semana pasada
Mario muy buenas noches Cuál fue la
reacción del presidente amlo a las
manifestaciones de ayer en varias
ciudades por lo visto descalificó de
nuevo a los asistentes y como han tomado
estos las críticas del mandatario
Hola qué tal Así es bueno el presidente
al principio minimizó la movilización
dijo que fueron de 80 a 100.000
asistentes cuando los organizadores
hablan de cerca de 500.000 pero más allá
de ellos de ello en efecto los
descalificó de nueva cuenta Dijo que
eran en su mayoría mapaches electorales
es decir tramposos dijo que defendían el
régimen de corrupción y fue más allá al
decir que defendían el narco estado que
prevaleció Durante los gobiernos de Fox
Y Felipe Calderón dijo que había también
entre los participantes delincuentes de
cuello blanco y después se fue por
minorizando con cada uno de los de las
principales figuras incluidos no
solamente políticos también por ejemplo
contra el activista Adrián lebarón a
cuyos familiares masacraron en Sonora en
2019 lo llamó lo llamó falsario y
supuesto defensor de Derechos Humanos
también a Emilio Álvarez icaza actual
senador y Quien fuera secretario
ejecutivo de la cidh le dijo manipulador
y también supuesto defensor de Derechos
Humanos ellos dos estos últimos dos
aludidos respondieron ya el activista de
Ale barón dijo que participó para
defender a la institución electoral y
que se cierre la puerta al crimen
organizado y dijo que si ser falsario es
ser solidario que lo mencione a diario
Álvarez y casa en tanto acotó que si
defender los derechos políticos también
es defender los derechos humanos y lo
harán cada que sea necesario Mario el
presidente y su partido alistan una
especie de contra marcha el próximo 18
de marzo que se sabe al respecto y cuál
es la convocatoria
así está como ocurrió en la pasada
movilización de noviembre de la
oposición que también tuvo su contra
marcha en esta ocasión de igual manera
el presidente convocó el 18 de marzo con
motivo de conmemorar la expropiación
petrolera y defender la soberanía
energética sin embargo bueno esto ya ha
sido interpretado como una contramarcha
incluso este día el líder del partido en
El poder del partido Morena hizo un
llamado a los 32 dirigentes estatales
del partido a que salgan a convocar a la
ciudadanía a defender dijo las reformas
del presidente López Obrador dijo que
iniciarán una campaña abierta a toda la
sociedad para dejar en claro que la
movilización de este domingo se hizo con
base en mentiras que es falso que se
quiera destruir al órgano electoral que
se quiera desaparecer la credencial de
elector y dijo que por ello van a salir
a las calles de manera masiva en lo que
consideró será una movilización
histórica
sin precedentes detalla de suerte que se
espera pues este contraste esta que
abona sin duda a la polarización entre
quienes apoyan al presidente y quienes
argumentan lo contrario y están en la
oposición